yeah akkacesia and people call it how do
i best describe it
and i wonder how your dad described it
but um
people call it the epitome of losing
their mind
basically because they are unable to
control the thoughts that they have it's
not just that it's also a physical
restless restlessness so a kind of inner
turmoil and a physical restlessness so
people pace they can't control their
their jerks their movements
um
it's probably one of the most horrible
conditions that anybody can find
themselves in
um
and
people commit suicide or die by suicide
um
for two reasons when it comes to
anesthesia
so
the first one is that they have no
control over their mind and their mind
is literally telling them to kill
themselves
the second is that it becomes so painful
and so unbearable that they feel that
they have no option
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 125.
in this episode beverly thompson joined
me to discuss prescription medications
like antidepressants and their effects
on those who depend on them
i debated whether or not to release this
episode because i don't want to
absolutely terrify people
antidepressants are a completely
misunderstood medication that cause
dependence
and people aren't aware of it so i'm
going to release it anyway
this is serious for me after being on
ssris specifically from the ages of 12
to 23 coming off of them caused me
severe depression sensitivity to sound
light touch
temperature and visual hallucinations
the worst symptom was a feeling of
overwhelming doom and panic
those symptoms are a huge part of the
reason i had to go to a zero carb diet i
got sensitive to carbs as well sugars
chemicals everything
it was to mitigate antidepressant
withdrawal
however i do believe there's hope for
people on them i got off of mine
and through the withdrawal and i'm doing
fine now i don't have withdrawal anymore
i'm putting out this video because
people need to know the dangers of these
medications going low carb and then zero
carb was insanely beneficial to me
getting off of these i don't know how i
would have done it without that don't
lose hope if you're on them and don't
suddenly stop
taking them which is what i did
talk to your doctor do your research
this is just an episode to help bring
awareness to the dangers of these
medications particularly upon sudden
cessation
my guest beverly thompson is a writer
researcher and speaker with a focus on
psychiatric medication like
antidepressants benzodiazepines and adhd
meds
beverly has intensely studied how these
medications work their history side
effects potential for dependence and the
effects of withdrawal beverly's worked
with the british medical association the
scottish government and the uk council
for evidence-based psychiatry
she drew a lot from those experiences to
write anti-depressed a breakthrough
examination of epidemic antidepressant
harm independence remember to hit
subscribe
if you learn anything or enjoy this
content
[Music]
beverly thompson welcome to the podcast
thank you
before we get started could you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure thank you so much for inviting me
to talk with you um i am a writer and a
researcher and for the past 10 years i
have been researching psychiatric
medication
my particular area of interest is
antidepressants
in particular
adverse effects and dependence
withdrawal
and
prescription drug induced suicide
particularly amongst the young
i have worked with organizations such as
the bma the council for evidence-based
psychiatry
um and the scottish government
and i've contributed to articles in the
bmj and in mainstream media
okay how did you get started doing this
work
my interest really started about 15
years ago when i was working in a
counseling role in schools
and i started to notice that the
language
around the children was starting to
change
and i started to notice people were
starting to say things like there's
something wrong with him or i think he's
got adhd or
and i started to question why we were
suddenly blaming children all their
brain chemistry a lot of the time
for how their their ability to cope with
what were often very very very very you
know serious life situations or family
situations or
things that they were dealing with at
school
and that's really where my interest
began
okay so you started with kids
yeah i started with kids
okay so do you know how this idea
do you know how our mental health
started going into the pharmaceutical
industry rather than being attributed to
life problems do you know the background
about how that happened
sure i mean it all started with prozac
in um
1988 and the mental health monster was
born
i mean i was in in 1988 by 2000 um i
think it was
illegally um a third of its three
billion pound profit came from the drug
prozac
so
the medical profession were taught at
that time
through various campaigns like defeat
depression and depression hurts that
all of a sudden we had a chemical
imbalance and this chemical imbalance
was what needed to be treated
so it was a chemical mouse in our brain
so suddenly everything that was going
wrong and our inability to cope with
life was our fault
so once ssri drugs were introduced into
society
we basically bought into the idea that
we had a chemical imbalance and we
needed a drug we needed a drug to fix it
to fix us
okay so that was 1988 so this is rather
recent
yeah
that's that yeah 1988 was um the first
ssri mr president
so this idea of a chemical imbalance do
you know where that came from like
how that theory even evolved
yeah well that there the it it came from
psychiatry so psychiatry have been very
good at manipulating
how we treat our mental health so they
have a book called a diagnostic and
statistic manual of mental disorders and
i call it probably the most influential
book that somebody's never heard of
it has at the moment i think over 300
diagnoses in it that we can be
given in order to be prescribed drugs or
medication to help us cope with things
so those terms like ocd and gad and
bipolar
were created by psychiatry
passed on to our primary care
so that they could diagnose us and they
could treat us with drugs
it's pretty simple really
okay
okay so i want to talk a bit about i've
talked about this on my podcast a couple
of times because i had horrifying
withdrawal
and really terrible side effects that i
wasn't aware of because i was prescribed
ssris at a young age
so
let's start off with
do you know percentage-wise is most of
your research based out of scotland or
do you know percentages for america
because i think america might be hit
almost the hardest with the
pharmaceutical whatever's going on in
psychiatry
yeah i do quote some statistics in my
book and yeah
north america i think they're at the
moment
about 45 million people who are taking
antidepressants and 2.1 million children
which is a huge number
and of course
because of the pandemic
the rates have increased sometimes
something between at one point it was
reported 20 percent
increases and for other drugs up to 40.
oh man
okay so um do you know do you have any
idea what happens to the brain when
people are on these medications for
extended periods of time
well that's the problem we really don't
and i think i heard your father
say once in a podcast that we're
randomly guessing
um and and that's pretty accurate you
know everything to do with these drugs
always comes with a caveat and if you
see things in you know a medical journal
or in a in research it always says it is
thought that
because we don't really know
i mean the chemical imbalance theory has
been tested
for 40 years
and it is still unproven
but saying that
the medical profession are still
repeating it non-stop i'll give you a is
it okay if i give you an example yeah
yeah for sure
one um this week on mainstream tv
with
something called this morning which is a
program that's in the morning on tv in
the uk and it has around two million
viewers every morning
and a gp who is the gp for the program
came on and
just this week quoted
was talking about
anti-depressants she quoted the chemical
imbalance theory she quoted that the
drugs are just like taking a drug for
diabetes yeah
she quoted that they can be taken a long
term and it's better if people do it
so what we're fighting against even
though a lot of research has been done
to to prove that a lot of things are
myths
the medical profession
backed by psychiatry and pharmaceutical
industry
really don't want to buy it
yeah
yeah okay so let's talk about
so
um
my audience is pretty familiar but like
i said i was on antidepressants i was on
ciprolex um from the age of 12 to 23 and
i stopped taking it over a period of two
weeks and it was
absolutely horrific and i had no idea
what was going on and i managed to
ameliorate some of
some of the withdrawal by going low carb
and like
not being around loud noises and bright
lights and but it was horrifying and it
took me two and a half years to figure
out that oh that was from abruptly
stopping antidepressants so could you
talk a bit and so part of the reason i'm
talking about it is because i've seen
this happen to a lot of people and
they're told it's their underlying
condition that's popping back up and
they're not aware that oh no this can be
actual withdrawal from a dependence you
didn't know you had on a medication you
were told you needed that was safe so
that's why i talk about this but can you
give me some examples of what you've
seen as common side effects of say
weaning or suddenly stopping these
antidepressants
well first of all i have to say that
nobody should ever stop taking
antidepressants called turkey
and yeah they should always take it with
the advice of
a medical professional or a support
service and that's another issue that i
hope we can talk about because yeah
um you know
they don't exist
and as you know when you were looking
for one with your father yeah yeah
um
so
the problem is that when
when this imbalance is we're told that
these drugs cure a chemical imbalance
but what they actually do is they create
an imbalance
so
you have basically
you
become
in a new balanced state
so this this drug is in
puts you in a new balance state which
affects you psychologically
physiologically and it affects every
single part of your your being it's not
just about the brain
so when you when you suddenly
and it can happen just missing one dose
and this is probably the first time that
people
realize that they're dependent on the
drugs
and then of these 45 million people
most people will be dependent and
actually not realize it if they've taken
the drugs for anything over sometimes
just six months people can become
dependent
um
so what happens is once you start to
decrease your body goes hey
hmm
something not right here
and what happens is basically you're
starting to become unbalanced again
so that new state that you become your
body and your mind have become used to
suddenly goes oh
don't know where i am right now don't
know what i'm dealing with
and that's where the withdrawal effects
come from
so basically a lot of the withdrawal
effects and neurological effects so it
can start with things like brain zaps
feeling sick you can have tremors
you can
have increased anxiety
if you look you can actually have all
the things that are listed in the
adverse effects so if you look at
a patient information leaflet for an
ssri drugs drug
you won't be surprised i'm sure you
won't be surprised to know that there
are about 50 that are listed as common
50 adverse effects
and there are about 140
that are listed
as uncommon or rare
now these uncommon or rare ones are not
uncommon and or rare and you'll be
surprised to hear that
drug dependence is actually listed as
uncommon
oh yeah okay
so you know it
they want us to keep taking these drugs
and the problem is that because we are
in this new balanced state every time we
try to reduce
we think
that we're ill again
now it would be very very very very very
hard for you to suddenly become
go back to that state that you were in
when you first started taking the drug
if you think about the position that you
were in then you know you might have
lost your job you might have
been in a relationship breakup you might
have had
of you know financial problems
but
how can you be suddenly going back to
the same state that you were in
so
withdrawal
is a huge problem and for many people
if they read my book they will realize
that
many people are not ever going to be
able to stop taking these drugs
and return to their normal state
and that's seriously worrying and that's
why we need education and we need people
especially young people
to start to realize
if you choose to take these drugs and
and you know you have every right to
take a drug if you want to take one
you need to be informed
you need to take it for no longer than
six months
if you want to
if you if you want to to reduce the harm
that these dogs can do
um everybody has a right to take them if
that's what they do but they also have a
right
they need to be an informed patient
sorry i'm probably
one thing that i was watching your dad's
um
podcast that you did with him
and i think everybody should watch it
it's really really interesting but
you know he said a few things that are
actually he said
i should have known these things
you know he said uh why the hell didn't
i see this coming and he said i didn't
understand them still until i started to
decrease
he's just the same as everyone else
i think these drugs are saving their
life they think that they can't survive
without them
but but the ironic thing is actually
they are getting to a point probably
where they can't survive without them
yeah it sounds like such a conspiracy
theory like if you're if you're not
aware if you're not aware it sounds like
such a conspiracy theory so i'd never
heard of
antidepressant withdrawal at all i like
i didn't know that they were dependents
forming at all and i had been actively
told that they weren't and so if i ever
i hardly ever missed a dose but if i
ever missed a dose i was like oh it's
the bipolar coming back so that horrible
feeling i was like that's my underlying
insanity
right uh and that's just that's what i
thought it wasn't until it and it really
did take like two and a half years after
i stopped taking them to realize that
it was drug withdrawal but i would say
people should be very aware and i talked
in another episode that there aren't
studies done i believe over eight weeks
of people on any psychiatric medication
which is crazy for
health professionals to say you can take
it long term safely because there aren't
any studies
and then
i have i've known a lot of people who've
used ways to taper down gradually and
get off of them but unfortunately like
the hard reality is i think especially
you can talk about this actually about
the age difference for when you're young
or when you're old but i know that the
percentage of elderly people who are on
these medications especially in nursing
homes is super high and those people
probably aren't getting off of these um
so it's definitely education is
definitely needed have you seen like say
this is something you start because like
i got off of everything and i'm okay now
but it was
the worst experience i've ever had for
years every day uh so
do you have ways let's talk about first
ways that you've learned of in order to
at least reduce the dose you're on
or potentially
reduce the dose let's start with that
okay
well the problem is that they have as
you said rightly say there are no
studies that have been done in terms of
how to reduce um
what we have are a few guidelines
very inadequate guidelines actually and
the american psychiatric association has
a guideline that hasn't been updated
since 2010
and we urgently need that to change
so
what we're finding is that the best
advice is actually anecdotal evidence
and that the best way we can learn is
from anecdotal evidence
so we have at the moment
what must be hundreds of thousands of
people's people who are in
you know sites online trying to support
each other through this actual process
because there are no guidelines from
professionals
what i talk about in my book is
something called the harm reduction
i compare it to suddenly getting up one
day and trying to run a 26 mile marathon
you can't do it it's impossible but what
you have to do is prepare yourself for
it
um
the only what the only thing we know is
time is your best friend so by hand
reduction
what i mean is what what what this means
is that you
you can't view it as an all or nothing
um thing because some people as i said
will never be able to get off these
drugs
never
some people will be would be able to
reduce and manage
their dosage
over time
but nobody should go into it
believing that they are actually going
to be able to come off these drugs 100
so time dose reduction there are some
fantastic
sites um
sites there are some fantastic there's
some fantastic literature and i have a
really really detailed resource section
in my book
because one thing that i wanted to do
was inform people
and i think that was another thing that
your dad said he wanted to inform people
so they don't go through this
you know
that was my book is not a medical book
it's not
an academic book it's written in a very
plain language that means that people
can pick it up they can dip in and out
they can take the information they need
and they can become informed about this
subject which is
really what we need everybody to do
yeah i would also say to reduce some of
the fear
because like you said
some people can't get off of this
which i believe is true especially with
age
and length of time and
dosage
but
there are definitely ways at least that
i've found to help with side effects and
to keep things stable
but
freaking out being like okay i'm
dependent on a drug and i didn't mean to
get dependent and i need to get rid of
it and then getting rid of it too
quickly can be completely disastrous and
can end up killing people like it makes
yeah can we make life so miserable that
it kills people so don't do that this
episode is brought to you by paleo
valley's 100 grass-fed beef sticks paleo
valley is a great company that's doing
amazing things for people's health
they're committed to making high-quality
clean products free of problematic
ingredients
and farming practices that don't harm
the environment
their products come from small
family-owned farms right here in the usa
that use rotational grazing if you want
to look that up i'm going to oxford to
debate on this actually rotational
grazing is the bomb diggity it's what
people should do for farming their cows
are never fed grains or harmful
antibiotics either so if you avoid meat
for environmental reasons and you're
still watching me for some reason you're
going to love paleo valley's grass-fed
and finished beef sticks now you've
probably heard some of the tricks
companies use for product taglines
did you know that companies can claim
their beef is grass-fed as long as it
was fed grass at some point in its life
or that meat can be marked american-made
even if only packaged in america
paleo valley on the other hand is the
real deal
i personally can't eat these because of
my lamb diet but if you guys are
snacking on pepperoni sticks or
something or need a snack that's
actually a healthy option you need to
lose some weight
this is a great option there are no
preservatives
no fillers just 100 american 100 grass
fed and finished beef from domestic
regenerative farms with organic spices i
can't eat it because i don't eat spices
but my brother is a huge fan
so check them out i wouldn't be
advertising them if i didn't support
this kind of product you can help your
body and the environment by trying paleo
valley's high quality protein today just
head over to
paleovalley.com and enter code mp for 15
off your first order that's paleo
valley.com with code mp for 15 off your
first order
can we talk a bit about say alternatives
to medication if there are people who
aren't on medication
yeah and i think you know the one thing
that we have to try and do now is
realize that we are being treated for
for conditions that are not made
actually medical conditions so we need
to start looking looking at ways and i
quote um daniels porous who is a
an ex u.n special recorder who has done
a lot about the ways that we should
start to think about mental health
nowadays
and it's about social prescribing it's
about um
you know support it's about going back
to looking at it
in terms of addressing the issues that
are making us
making it difficult to cope with our
lives and not about
taking drugs that are
to create
to cure a chemical imbalance i think he
talks about we need to address personal
and societal factors
and not address chemical imbalances and
i think that's the way that we have to
go so you know things like people need
to start looking at
alternatives they have to look at their
diet they have to look at less social
social time on social media they have to
look at their exercise they have to
to
to to take up a hob i mean not everybody
can do these things but if we can it
certainly is a great alternative to
becoming anti-depressed
yeah it's also effective right so for me
and for my dad there weren't one of the
things that was confusing about being
diagnosed with depression is there
weren't aspects of our lives
exactly there were some but there
weren't major aspects that were
completely out of place so relationship
was solid job was solid
those are two areas that can cause
depression uh i was quite ill as a child
with an autoimmune disorder and that was
really stressful for my family but dad's
depression started before i was born
so that ended up now we know that ended
up being
entirely i would say caused by diet and
his just his response to diet and so it
could have been ameliorated by diet
um so if people
have looked into different areas of
their life so like relationships
you know job
money
and if there are problems there you can
fix go there and if nothing seems out of
place and you're still miserable then
you have to start looking at your health
because inflammation can because a cause
of depression and antidepressants aren't
going to fix the underlying problem
they're just going to band-aid it and
even then
it they don't like i i me being on them
i remember it felt like they helped
initially but then i i was numb and
depressed and it was better than just
being depressed and feeling that raw
emotion but it did not pay off in the
end
the end was terrible so there are ways
you can get around yet yeah yeah and
most people you know if you if you think
about it most of us if we
if we think about it
realistically
we can probably work out the things in
our lives that are making it difficult
for us to cope with it to cope with life
and it doesn't mean that we all have the
ability to to to um to deal with them
you know but things like i mean i know
in the states for example there's a huge
lack of
access to psychological therapy there's
a huge lack of counsellors there's a
lack of
psychiatrists and psychologists
and these issues really seriously need
to dress but you don't have to talk to a
professional
and actually it doesn't have to be a
conversation about your mental health
it can just be a conversation about your
life
and how you're feeling
and that's a huge start
yeah that's a very good point and if
you're not comfortable talking to
someone you can also write like some
people who are who are super introverted
you just try and write out what's making
you not feel good in your head like here
are the problems even just identifying
the problems can help you work on them
yeah i mean i i i think so and and you
know most not everybody can
access things and and you know we have
major problems and one of the problems
in the states i think that is huge
problem especially for elderly people
is loneliness you know and how do we
deal with this but but most people
elderly people who are lonely have been
prescribed antidepressants
and we have to stop this this is not
doing this is not good for people who
need our care and our love to be
prescribing their mind-altering drugs at
a time when they're most vulnerable
what are the alternatives then
for say say the elderly and for this
loneliness
because
saying and i'm i'm full on i'm pretty
anti-antidepressants after what happened
to me
but for the sake of the argument like
say you're dealing with people older
people and their family isn't caring for
them and they're in old folks homes and
they're unhappy
like that would mean an entire system
overhaul which we just
how are we supposed to do that
well that's a very good question how are
you supposed to do that
um you know and it is a society issue
but the more of the mental health
monster these the mental health messages
aren't keeping us healthy at all you
know disability rates are shooting
through the roof and this is because we
have bought into this factor whatever
age we are if we have problems hoping
we're mentally ill
um
it's a difficult one because it is
societal changes that are needed it's
not individual changes we can support
more we can but some people just don't
have somebody there and they depend on
society to help them
okay
children especially as well you know i
think we have to start asking the
question
is it morally
is it morally the right thing to do to
medicate children with mind-altering
drugs does any do we have the right to
do that
so when i was yeah i agree i agree
especially with things like adhd and
like maybe like especially with things
like adhd but
for this is the position my parents were
in because i've had a lot of people and
they're like well why were you put on
something at the age of 12 and so
which ended up really
not
doing me well you know in the end when i
stopped taking it abruptly but
at the time they were dealing with
somebody with an autoimmune disorder and
i was having ocd tendencies to try like
organizing things like late into the
night uh extreme anxiety night terrors
and i wouldn't say suicidal ideation but
i was getting to the point where i was
like maybe it would be better if i was
dead and that could have been
and i've tried to figure it out right
and it could have been partly a response
to being sick
and it could have been the inflammatory
response my body was
provoking but in that period of time
when we were unaware that diet played
such a major factor
it was like what do we do she can't
survive like this here's medication
and so i guess
education is what's needed that there
are alternatives so yeah
i think the problem is that most parents
have already bought into the fact that
just like them their children probably
have a chemical imbalance that needs
so they've already bought into this
narrative
and they see no reason why
their children shouldn't be medicated
too but you know i i do you know i do
feel sorry for children for parents
because they're kind of in a lot of
cases damned if they do and damned if
they don't
um
but
the one thing that we do need to start
looking at is the suicide rate for
children who are prescribed
antidepressants is
you know
skyrocketing and twice i think that
twice as likely 2.5 times as likely to
have a suicidal event as unmedicated
children
okay that's definitely something we
should touch on then yeah so
okay so i guess the other side of the
argument would be well aren't those
children already more inclined towards
suicide attempts without the medication
and so how do we know that it's the
medication that's increasing this
suicidal ideation
yeah there are a number of
robust studies that have been done that
i include in my book um
and um
yeah and they've recently been looked at
again very recently and and they are
very robust studies so um it's worth
people having a look at those but
whether you
choose to medicate a child i think what
you have to do is like i've said before
it's even more important that you become
a responsible informed
person in terms of what these drugs do
you know we live in the age of the
consumer you know we have access
to so much information online you know
we have access i think we do something
like
3.5 billion google searches a day
you know we google how to work mccann we
google
ridiculous things
why don't we why
don't we take some responsibility
and find out more about these these
drugs um we need to we really need to
start doing it
and i think i think times are changing
and i think people are starting to ask
more and more questions which can only
be a good thing
yeah well i hope so and i helped talking
about these kind of things making
it more acceptable i certainly had no
idea
uh
some of the effects these drugs have i
think for the let's talk about this
suicidality that can occur with
antidepressant use and like you said
studies show that it is increased
and people i think what happened in my
head when i learned about that was
what i just said was well aren't these
people more
more and more inclined towards suicidal
ideation to begin with and how do you
know it's the medication causing it not
just the person
but
i think we should touch on akathesia a
bit which is a fairly common
it's it's listed in the rare side
effects but it's not particularly rare
uh so could we touch on that what that
is and
what that looks like
okay academia is i call it the a word of
antidepressants
because i think it's the word that
everybody um needs to understand if they
start to take antidepressants
it's a neurological condition that can
happen mostly when people start taking
the drug when they change dose and when
they or when they've stopped taking um
the antidepressants it can also happen
with change of generics so if you're
suddenly given
if you're suddenly given a drug
that's a different make of drug
the by equivalence can be anything
between 80 and 120
so what
yeah you suddenly might go into
involuntary withdrawal just by just by
being given a i think it's only
something like 10 of drugs that are
prescribed in the states now that are
branded drugs
i had no idea the dosages could be
changed that's so dangerous
yeah it's not just the quality of the
drugs it's it's you know i see now so
many times
that people who are given a different
generic
are almost going into
what could be termed withdrawal
wow it's happening so much
um so yeah academia and people call it
how do i best describe it
and i wonder if you how your dad
described it but um
people call it the epitome of losing
their mind
basically because they are unable to
control
the thoughts that they have
it's not just that it's also a physical
restless restlessness so a kind of inner
turmoil and a physical restlessness so
people pace they can't control their
their jerks their movements
um
it's probably one of the most horrible
conditions that anybody can find
themselves in
um
and
people commit suicide or die by suicide
um
for two reasons
when it comes to academia
so
the first one is that they have no
control over their mind and their mind
is literally telling them to kill
themselves
the second is that it becomes so painful
and so unbearable
that they feel that they have no option
and this is the saddest saddest part of
antidepressants
if somebody is in that state you've seen
it yourself
it is basically like losing your mind
and it's horrible and we really really
need more information more education
there are some fantastic sites so there
there's um
academia 101 which is a continuing
education program which is free and is
online
and anybody can can can go and do that
and there's an amazing organization
called axesia education i think it's
uh a cathedral axis alliance for
education and research which which is
doing some fantastic work to try and
make people more aware of this condition
the problem is that again
people will if they become a cathedral
that people will say it's a relapse
he's mentally ill again she's mentally
ill again
it's her
mania it's her
the problem is that a lot of people
think that they have become psychotic
so
a lot of first episodes psychosis as
people call it the first time they
become psychotic is actually arkansas
it's actually drug induced
and i think this is i mean i would love
i mean it's fantastic that you are
someone like yourself is actually trying
to create awareness and i think if
academia is one area that
really really needs to ex to be explored
and people really need to understand the
commit
the condition
yeah and i would say
i um
yeah that was the worst thing i've ever
seen
yep yeah and i've seen some pretty bad
things like i've had sick family members
i've seen alzheimer's i've seen cancer
i've seen i've been through surgeries
that was the worst thing i've ever seen
by far
yeah and i think it's the worst thing
because
there isn't there is nothing that
anybody can do
i have seen people from easier for 10
years 12 who i i seriously
their life has become
basically unlivable
and this is a lot of it is is chronic
brain impairment and a lot of it is that
their central nervous system has just
become so damaged
that without the drugs they can't
survive
yeah so my dad's out of it right and he
his was bad his was like some of the
worst acather that specialists had ever
seen and it took us years to figure out
how to get rid of it um and i'm not
saying that this is
i'm gonna tell people what we did but
i'm not saying that this is what's going
to work because there's no information
out there
but um low-dose murtazapine
um helped
with and and so that didn't which was
just
a miracle
um
and then there are case studies on
opiates
and people are scared of taking those
because of the withdrawal but there are
case studies of that helping academia
and if you're dealing with somebody with
acathelia which can like manifest like
you said like bipolar or schizophrenia
manifest as so it's misdiagnosed as that
getting those people more comfortable is
highest priority no matter what this
isn't
this isn't something people can tolerate
and live with this is something that's
so uncomfortable that they commit
suicide so it doesn't matter what you
have to do but if you can find something
that helps you just use it because those
people are in a lot of pain so there are
case studies on opiates helping um and
they helped dad
tremendously
um and then the other thing we did which
is
super controversial but it's what helped
me is i'm on this
extremely strict diet so we got rid of
all carbs
and if dad isn't on this his academia
comes back which is completely absurd
and it isn't recognized by the medical
community but that's what happens to me
too so we're not sure if it's permanent
nervous system damage that's just
provoked really easily or what's going
on but
that's what helped us but provoking one
of the reasons you don't want to
suddenly stop taking your medication is
you don't want to provoke academia
yeah absolutely and um the testimonials
in my book are
so many of them
are tell of
people suffering from academia and how
they coped a bit and the actual pain and
tumult that they went through in their
lives and it it's absolutely
heartbreaking but we need to we need to
learn about this we really do
well hopefully people are learning i
know with benzodiazepine use they put a
black box warning on it in the last year
or so but it needs to be something that
all medical professionals know so that
they're not just saying oh this kid like
even with
even with a kid who's really misbehaving
and really depressed and really angry
uh
which is a huge problem because you
don't want to be around a kid like that
the kid's unhappy like i can understand
having a difficult child who's unhappy
but trying to go the more natural route
and fixing diet first and then and
trying other things
otherwise you can provoke some of these
side effects that are fairly common do
you know how common
experiencing academia is for
antidepressant use
no i don't have any statistics but i
know it's much more common than we
realize and as you say it's off it's
it's very often misdiagnosed as
something else
so it would at the moment i think be
very difficult to get actual statistics
one of the things that really concerns
me about anesthesia is um
i talk a lot about in my book about
vulnerability and how antidepressants
make you very vulnerable and in lots of
lots of situations but one of the things
that that we're seeing is
if if a child is put on a drug say at 12
years old
eventually that child becomes an adult
so they might go off to university
they might make decisions for themselves
they might say to themselves i don't
really want to take this drug anymore i
don't and if they are not informed we
are seeing so many young people
who suddenly decide to stop taking their
medication or change their medication
become
[Music]
have academia and commit and and and end
up dying by suicide
and and this is so common and this is
another of the areas we need key
education
is to to to young people to adolescents
to tell them that they really really
need to take responsibility for their
own medication they really really need
to
understand that they cannot stop taking
this suddenly
and so that that that transition between
being a child and an adult
when somebody made that decision
for you that you will go on that
medication suddenly you're responsible
for yourself yourself and unless you
have the information there unless you
have been educated by your parents
you're suddenly in a very vulnerable
place
yeah
it would be nice if and this is
something i think should be mandatory in
america if this is possible but it
people should be educated about this in
high school like the percentage of kids
on medication is so high that this
should be a mandatory course in high
school and it should say hey you know
it should teach you about these mental
disorders
what different medications are and what
the side effects can be and often are i
don't know if that's ever gonna happen
or how that would start but the
percentage of people on psychiatric
medications
do you know what it is is it one in five
is it more than that in america
one and four
oh
yeah okay so one in four and that's just
like you said increased because of the
pandemic
i think it's about one in four but i
think we're still waiting for statistics
uh recent statistics to come out canada
is actually i tried to get statistics
for canada before i i was speaking to
you but it was quite difficult to
actually get up-to-date statistics for
canada
yeah there are many things difficult
about canada right now
but um you um you have always been in i
think in the top five countries in terms
of antidepressant consumption
yeah do you have any idea why they're
so much higher in the states versus
other countries
um i i think it's it
it's just that um they oh direct
consumer advertising has got a huge huge
role or obviously if if
we're seeing adverts on tv
then you know we're going to walk into a
a doctor's surgery and ask for a drug
um and there's been a lot of talk
recently about you know should direct
consumer advertising be banned and the
answer is of course it should because
it's a very bad way of educating people
about medication because all they're
basically doing is selling it um
it it needs to stop i think i think
there's only america and new zealand
that allow direct consumer advertising
yeah that's insane they don't allow that
in canada for sure
yeah
yeah i think it's just yeah it's just
the two um
and and it it it plays a huge part in in
i mean
the number of i think i've got a section
in my book actually the number of
anti-depressant adverts that are on tv
it's
it's crazy they spend millions
uh and and and people are seeing these
from a very young age and they think
it's just a natural thing to do you know
it's just an actual part of life if you
if you're if you're not coping you go
get a drug you take the drug and hey
but the problem is the problem is that
as you and your dad discovered
once you get to that point of um
of struggling and you need help there's
nowhere to find it
yeah
other than like you said anecdotal
reports from people online who are all
desperate trying to help each other
trying whatever
might work yeah it's a
it's a
complete catastrophe and we went the
crazy thing was we went everywhere like
we talked to everybody and
everybody made it worse
basically because it was just like oh
add this on add this on oh it's this you
know oh it's schizophrenia or it's
bipolar
you know
and
and even though we're aware no this is
acaethesia and this is the cause what
can we do
nothing also worked like all the the
medications for academia that people are
given are generally benzodiazepines but
if benzodiazepines benzodiazepines are
causing academia in the first place
then like what are you supposed to do
yeah but it but again it's all about
people thinking that they have to
rebalance which is basically what they
do have to do but that's not the help
that people want you know people want
help with
the actual medication that they're
taking it's quite crazy in the states if
you look then if you google
antidepressant
withdrawal you'll find some very
luxurious places that really relieve you
of
tens of thousands of dollars
to get rid of your
antidepressant problem in weeks
yeah
they can't do it they just cannot do it
it's not a problem that can be solved in
weeks
it's a problem that most of the time
takes people years to do it successfully
and without any harm um
but people are buying into the fact that
they think these most of them are
realistic drug or um
alcohol rehabilitation places are and
but most people are buying to the fact
that if they have the money let's give
it a try
it needs to stop
yep
i agree
okay do i have more i think we covered
most of the things i wanted to talk
about is there anything you want to talk
about specifically other than what we've
already covered
um i think i
i would love to talk more about the
generic concept because i think that is
is a really
interesting thing that people need to
know about so if we take prozac
is this okay if i talk about this yeah
yeah yeah let's do that
if we take prozac as an example so i
think prozac was in the states was
launched in 1988 and it lost its patent
in 2001
so then
fluoxetine the generic name the drug
could be made by
any pharmaceutical company that wants to
make it
so they they basically apply for what is
called an ander so it's an abbreviated
new drug application
so they send that off to the studio
and the fda looks at it and um they
don't actually the easiest way for me to
describe it is they don't get the recipe
for prozac
so they don't see how
lily actually made prozac they don't so
all they have to do
anything i can see your face only
all they have to do is prove similarity
wow
okay so that's all they have to do they
prove that
its effects are similar
so
we are now having drugs from india for
china from
very little regulation over where these
drugs are made there's very little
control over the quality of these drugs
there are some excellent books actually
if you're going to put some resources on
this i'd love to send you some things
that i can yeah i'll do that i'll do
that
yeah absolutely fantastic um and
especially the academia
site um so they have to prove that the
drugs are similar that's all they have
to do
so every time you fill a
prescription nowadays you might be
getting a different makeup drug
every time you get a new
prescription a new script
so
we can go from 80 by equivalence to 120
back to 80 back to 120 the quality
of the ingredients might be different
they
and this is one of the things that is
making patients really really vulnerable
because if they especially if they're
trying to withdraw
so imagine you're trying to withdraw
so
and you you're not being given the same
drug every time
it makes it really difficult
really really difficult so generics in
terms of antidepressants are presenting
a huge
problem oh that's really interesting so
i didn't know that
because then i don't think anybody knows
that yeah
yeah i think it's one of the things that
we really start to need to start doing
more research when we really start
looking at it's really important that if
people are withdrawing they try and take
the same drug all the time but it's
impossible because the because of the
availability of drugs i mean especially
at the moment
every time somebody i don't know whether
it's i would imagine it's even worse in
canada and not america but you know
every time in the uk somebody goes and
and and fills the script then
they're basically getting a different
drug
wow
okay
it's interesting
very interesting
so um
yeah
yeah that is interesting you'd think
that that i mean
people automatically assume that
everything in the world is just set up
more properly than it is so it's like oh
yeah you know the pharmacist asks you do
you want
do you want this brand or do you want
the generic brand it's cheaper and so
your assumption is well they're the same
but one's cheaper and i don't need
something fancy it's like brand name
clothing right who cares it's like oh no
they don't even make it the same way
necessarily but it's back to that issue
that you know we have to appreciate that
we are consumers we are consumers of
these drugs and we are paying for them
whether it be through insurance when you
tax we are paying for them and we
deserve
to get the quality drugs that we should
get
i agree
okay
beverly thank you very much for coming
on i'll link your book below but for
everybody listening can you just
reiterate what your book is and where to
find you online
yeah sure my book is called ant
depressed
it's a breakthrough examination of
antidepressant harm and dependence
and what i've done is i've written a
book that is
as i called it in plain language it's
not a medical book it's not an academic
book it's a book so that people can
become informed users of antidepressants
i haven't said in the book that people
should not take these drugs what i've
said in the book is if they take them
they need to know about the harms and
the benefits of the drug
so where they can find me um
i am
at tap support tap support on twitter i
am at
med consulting um and i will give you a
couple of sites that you can put in the
links
that would be great yes thank you thank
you very much for coming on
no thank you so much for
for um
for inviting me to talk with you it's
been really interesting and it's lovely
to meet you
[Music]
you